jeopardy james is back at it again but
this time he's paying it forward
the local las vegas raising money for an
incredible cause to fight pancreatic
cancer
eight news now got an exclusive
interview with him to find out more
about his cause
you're off to a great start how unusual
jeopardy james is all in again a 28-day
total of 2 million
195 000 but this time he's
not winning money he's raising it for a
remarkable cause
this is one of the absolute top-rated
charities out there the pancreatic
cancer action network or
pancan has their purple stride event
saturday march 20th
they consider the event the walk to end
pancreatic cancer
james holtz hour is from las vegas he is
a professional
sports gambler james jumped into
fundraise for a jeopardy friend
i set a fundraising goal of eight
thousand two hundred forty four dollars
it's a number of
episodes amsterdam hosted on jeopardy um
and i'm i'm proud to say that
donations have come flooding in james is
already at 150 percent of his goal and
wants to keep it going it's all in for
alex you know and i have my face
all in with the ship's move boom the
event different this year
they'll mail you a shirt if you rate
fundraise i believe it's at least 25
and you know you go for a walk somewhere
safe and distance
and you you show off your colors and you
show that you're participating in the
fight
and you know i think it's it's great the
money you donate
funds research programs and clinical
initiatives and
helps patients navigate pancreatic
cancer
with every dollar raised james thoughts
are with trebek's legacy
and reflecting on alex's consistent
courage during his battle
i want to be a positive influence in
terms of the message
i send them and that is that hey
stay the course yes keep your chin up
talk to him after the game phantom
promised that i shook his hand that he'd
fight this thing all the way he uh he
gave me a nod in the smile and really
you know i think i calculated he hosted
something like 300
episodes after that point so went down
swinging for sure
james told us about what became a warm
relationship with the legend
i can tell you this you know he poured
his heart into that job he
there were times when you could tell he
was really
laboring to get through the day but he
brought it up on that stage and
you know i think that we can all take it
some inspiration from that brian loftis
8 news now
well the purple stride event is a stride
your own weight event this year due to
covet 19
pancan is asking all participants to
walk in your own
in your own neighborhoods for a cause
now registration is free and anything
you donate or fundraise
goes to the fight against pancreatic
cancer now you can do either at
purplestride.org we also have that link
at eightnewsnow.com where of course
brian's story will be
posted in just a matter of minutes and
of course you can watch
jeopardy weeknights here at seven
o'clock right here on channel eight
katie kirk is going to be wrapping up
for two weeks as guest host friday then
we've got dr oz and aaron rodgers all
next
in line have a great evening thank you
so much